With sci-fi adventure and cast of cosmic misfits
that includes a talking raccoon and his best
friend, a tree, it’s no surprise that Marvel’s
Guardians of the Galaxy was a big hit for
kids when it hit theaters.
All the adults who saw it, however, might’ve
noticed a few other things that flew right
over the younger viewers’ heads.
Destination Earth
Even though he was taken from Earth as a child
and raised among the outlaws known as the
Ravagers, one of the key components of Peter
Quill’s character is his intense connection
to his homeworld.
It’s exemplified through the Awesome Mix
cassette tape, given to him by his mother
before she died, which he listens to nonstop
to form the film’s soundtrack.
When we see Peter as an adult, it’s been
26 years since he was abducted into space
by the Ravagers, and he’s still holding
onto the mixtape, his backpack, a Troll doll,
and the few other mementos he has of his old
home.
He’s also a capable pilot who knows his
way around the galaxy and even has his own
spaceship, named after the decidedly Earth-based
celebrity Alyssa Milano, so… he definitely
tried to go back to Earth at some point, right?
Maybe not recently, since he seems to have
settled into the life of a space-faring outlaw,
but it’s hard to imagine a universe in which
Star-Lord didn’t run away from the Ravagers
and head back home at the first chance he
got, even if it was just to see if the Jackson
5 ever put out another song.
Unfortunately, that’s not a story we’ve
ever seen, unless he spent a few years undercover
in Pawnee, Indiana.
"There's only one man for the job: Burt Macklin."
Tale of the Tape
Peter's trusty Walkman, and the mixtape contained
within it, are more than just a playlist.
It’s his main attachment to the memory of
his mother, and it became the essential hallmark
of the film, too.
It's embedded in the very fabric of the Guardians
of the Galaxy franchise, so much so that when
he has to escape from space prison, Peter
risks his life and his freedom just to get
the tape back.
And it also represents a genuine miracle in
audio preservation technology.
As anyone who was actually around in the ‘80s
knows, cassette tapes aren’t exactly the
most durable format, especially if you’re
playing them over and over for, say 26 years.
And yet, Peter’s mixtape and the walkman
he uses to play it are in perfect working
condition after being bounced around the universe
for a quarter of a century.
And that's not the only tape-tech Peter has.
Either Sony has a repair tech in Knowhere,
or Peter just happened to run into the only
member of the Nova Corps who could hook him
up with a tape deck pulled straight out of
the dashboard of a custom van.
Zero G
When the team is taken to the Kyln prison,
it's up to Rocket to come up with a way to
get out, and what he comes up with actually
ends up working pretty well.
The escape plan hinges on the team getting
up into the guard tower, turning off the artificial
gravity in the prison, and then simply flying
away.
It's a good idea, but it also involves at
least one very large chunk of luck.
For some reason, when the artificial gravity
goes off, the Kyln guards, many of whom had
previously been holding riot shields and rocket
launchers, just start madly flailing around
as they float.
Not only do they never recover as the Guardians
make their escape, they also drop their weapons.
Obviously, suddenly losing gravity would have
an element of surprise, but if you’re going
to build a super-secure prison in the depths
of space, you’d think training your guards
to fight in zero G would be one of the first
things you’d do.
The second thing?
Telling them not to drop their guns at the
first sign of trouble.
The Ravager diet
Peter is abducted from Earth as a boy by the
Ravagers, a group of outlaws with their own
code and system of command who were hired
by Peter's still-mysterious father to bring
him back.
Yondu, the leader of this particular faction
of Ravagers, decides to keep Peter and raise
him like a murderous, outer space Mary Poppins.
“I’m Mary Poppins, y’all!”
Rather than dosing his medicine with a spoonful
of sugar, though, Yondu keeps young Peter
in line by reminding him that he saved him
more than once from being eaten by his fellow
Ravagers.
They seem pretty eager to find out what creatures
from this distant planet called Earth taste
like.
"When I picked you up on Terra…"
"Picked me up."
"...these boys of mine wanted to eat you."
"Yeah?"
"They ain't never tasted any Terran before.
I stopped 'em!"
So are Ravagers space cannibals, or do they
just consider human beings to be livestock?
They’re made up of all manner of alien species,
so if they were that willing to drop a clearly
sentient Peter Quill onto their plates at
lunchtime, have they also eaten members of
each others’ species, too?
That could make for some pretty awkward conversation
around the table, but the movie never bothers
to answer this question, even though we’re
hungry for answers.
Love and the single alien
Star-Lord definitely fits into the "lovable
scoundrel" category, and apparently that includes
all definitions of “lovable.”
He apparently has a tendency toward meaningless
flings with all manner of alien species.
He has a woman, whose name he's forgotten,
in his ship when we first meet him, he hits
on Gamora when he sees her, and later he tells
Drax various stories about alien women who've
attacked him after he romanced his way out
of, and into, plenty of trouble.
If you’ve ever watched Star Trek and seen
Captain Kirk’s attitude towards the prime
directive when it comes to green women, you
already know this isn’t exactly a new element
for sci-fi.
Still, we have to ask: do all humanoid-looking
aliens have compatible reproductive organs?
The only elaboration we get from Peter is
a story about flirting with a woman who had
"tentacles and needles for teeth."
He says he only spent time with her in a quest
for information, but what would have happened
if he'd taken that interaction to the next
level?
Maybe we're better off not knowing.
Lazy, Lazy Thanos
After Avengers: Infinity War, we all know
Thanos as a supervillain who could be not
just a mastermind, but a punishing and relentless
force.
Before Infinity War, though, his major abilities
seem less built around fistfighting gods,
and more about delegating tasks to lesser
villains.
This is especially evident in Guardians of
the Galaxy.
As he did in The Avengers, Thanos sends someone
else, Ronan the Accuser, to obtain an Infinity
Stone for him.
Rather than doing anything himself, he spends
all of his time seated on a floating throne
in space, hurling threats and giving orders
but never actually showing the audience why
he's so dangerous.
It definitely works in the context of the
larger MCU, but if you were to watch this
film on its own, you'd essentially just be
taking everyone at their word that Thanos
is a bad dude.
Here, he's basically a guy who tells everyone
else to go do something for him while he kicks
back and gets irritated when they fail.
No wonder Ronan decided to strike out on his
own when he realized he had an Infinity Stone
in his possession.
Mint condition
When the Guardians realize they need to get
rid of the Orb before it falls into the wrong
hands, Gamora's plan is to sell it to the
Collector, an ancient and powerful being who…
well, collects things.
If they give it to him, she reasons, they
can both no longer be responsible for it and
get paid.
The Collector is happy to oblige, but while
the group is in his home he notices something
else he'd like to buy: Groot.
"You must allow me to pay you now so that
I may own your carcass… at the moment of
your death, of course."
While it's certainly nice of him to pay up
front and wait for Groot to live a full life,
the film also makes it pretty clear that the
Collector has no such scruples about other
specimens in his collection.
Numerous living, seemingly sentient things
are visible in his display cases, including
Marvel’s own Cosmo the Space Dog and Howard
the Duck.
Here’s hoping they were offered a better
deal than the one Groot was going to get.
You know how to whistle, don’t you?
Of all the interesting space technology on
display in Guardians of the Galaxy, there’s
nothing more intriguing than Yondu’s Yaka
Arrow.
Lifted straight from the comic page, the incredible
sharp and fast weapon is controlled through
whistling and a technological fin on Yondu’s
head, and it’s powerful enough to slaughter
a whole group of enemies with a simple melody.
It's a neat piece of gear, and while it's
certainly very effective in its current form,
it's hard to watch the Yaka Arrow in action
and wonder why Yondu isn't thinking bigger.
Sure, the Arrow is elegant, but what about
a rocket launcher that works the same way,
or a drone, or a whole ship?
Perhaps it requires more mental energy and
control than Yondu's whistle can summon, or
maybe it’s just limited by being in range
of the whistle’s sound, meaning that he
couldn’t fly the arrow through the silent
depths of space, but it seems like they might
be shooting pretty low.
Even though it's remarkably effective.